Hi I'm Desmond Patton, I'm a new fellow
here at the Berkman Klein Center and
I'm a professor at the School of Social
Work at Columbia University.
I'm from Gastonia North Carolina which is
a small town outside of Charlotte
North Carolina, I'm a country boy!
This year I'm really trying to understand how
communication on social media leads to
offline violence and so I'm studying a
Twitter dataset of young people in Chicago to better understand how things like grief
and trauma and love and happiness all
play out on Twitter and the relationship
between that communication and offline gun violence.
So I started my research process in Chicago and I have been
just completely troubled by the amount of
violence that happens in the city.
And one of the ways in which that violence
happens or occurs is through social
media communication. And so I want to be
a part of the process of ending violence
through learning how young people communicate online.